so it was last summer that everything
changed completely particularly in the
business we're in
the news business and all of a sudden
coverage in this country started to
resemble a game of mad libs remember
that remember that game
you could pick a noun any noun and
someone on national television would be
denouncing that noun
as racist punctuality racist
ice cream trucks super racist
shakespeare white supremacy
at one point it got so crazy that the
feds told abc news that
national parks were somehow racist
the national park service says the
persistent whiteness of its 419
parks is an existential crisis the
american wilderness a playground for
old and for young and overwhelmingly
white when you look around you don't see
people that you identify with
you don't feel welcome you feel out of
place you
feel literally like you are an outsider
so here's the game here's how it's
played those sound like complaints oh
poor me but they're not complaints
they're attacks yes they are and they're
continuing in fact they've accelerated
the washington post
has now decided and this is a real
headline
in fact it's only monday but we're
starting with
the most amazing story of the year
here's the quote the racist
legacy many birds carry birds like
avian animals that fly the post included
a sketch
of an innocent looking jamison's fire
finch now that bird might look red
but deep down the washington post tells
us it's white as in
white supremacist of course bird bigotry
is
needless to say systemic so according to
the washington post other avian
oppressors include the
bachmann sparrow the wallace's fruit
dove
and the autobahn's warbler the warbler
the warbler is named that one is named
after john james
autobahn the guy who literally wrote the
book on bird watching
he's of course been canceled because he
was impressive
he thought about things other than
himself he observed the natural world
and wrote and painted it
but that doesn't go far enough just
cancelling autobahn you can do more than
that because as ibrahim x kendi taught
us it's not enough to simply oppose
bird racism we must become actively
anti-bird
we must defund and dismantle all sips of
systems of bird supremacy
immediately or else we're implicated in
those systems we need to decolonize
every bird's nest
until we do the work bird racism has the
high ground it's literally
dumping on us not just our institutions
our windshields
and it's not coming off
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else